well millions of people in Northeast
face another day of dangerous cold from
the deadly polar vortex as the Midwest
deals with the lingering effects of the
frigid blast the fields like temperature
is far below zero from Minnesota to
Maine this morning
and at least 20 deaths are connected to
the storm dramatic warming is ahead
before another brutal winter system is
expected to sweep across the country
next week Adriana Diaz is in Chicago
where the cold weather broke records
Adriana good morning good morning well
the peak of the polar vortex has passed
over the Midwest it is still in the
single digits here and Chicago got
another dusting of snow last night on
top of the already frozen ground and icy
waterways while people are still digging
out and dealing with heavy doses of snow
and cold across parts of the Northeast
in the Midwest others are working
through the tail end of the polar vortex
the crunching of thick ice is music to
the ears of the crew of fire boat engine
to the Chicago Fire Department's
icebreaker how thick is the ice the
thickest we went through today is
probably about a foot Wow and that's ice
that had been broken yesterday yeah it
had been broken about a refrozen
chuckles pilot Bob London says this is a
necessary process to stop people from
walking on the frozen Chicago River and
to clear a path for other boats as the
thaw begins other problems are likely to
pop up like ice jams and rivers that
raise the risk of flooding or water main
breaks like this one in Chicago from
days of sub-zero temperatures in
Milwaukee County police are
investigating two additional deaths that
might be connected to the extreme cold a
62 year old man was found frozen in his
backyard Thursday and on Wednesday a 38
year old woman died in an unheated
apartment I'm still kind of in shock
like knowing that a lady just died
upstairs that she just froze to death
below average temperatures might return
to the Midwest and the Northeast next
week but if there's any good news it's
that it likely won't be as cold as this
week's polar vortex John Adriana thank
you we can only hope